[Music]
poor of the panel you're the one who
seems to me most clearly behind the idea
of there being an absolute good so how
do you defend the idea of the absolute
good of there being an absolute good
given that the suicide bomber and the
pacifist have radically different
accounts it's just one of them wrong yes
it can't be no how do you decide well so
there is there is the question of
whether there is a truth maker as it
were for a dispute there you have to you
have to be careful and interpret the
dispute first so and and let me just say
one very quick thing here because the
the notion of an absolute good it I was
interpreting it to mean objective
meaning independent of the attitudes of
the disputants there is another thing
that's at work which is this idea of
some ultimate good is that there are
many many goods and we can all agree
there are objectively good but is there
some ultimate good these are two
different issues here and there there
somehow rolled into rolled into that
word so right now for me what matters
rather than the idea of some thing of on
which you cannot improve is just the
issue of the objectivity of the value
claims that are so can you explain that
a little bit further so this idea of the
ultimate good being different from the
objectively good I mean what do you see
if something is objectively good doesn't
that mean that it is in a sense
ultimately good it's that's just well
though it is all I was saying is that so
you think you know you can have a
question about whether in a dispute one
position is more correct than the other
one Oh correct where's what
with the other one being false and
therefore you can think that some some
acts are better than others without
necessarily thinking that there is some
terminus to which we all have to aim
what we have to aim you know suppose
that the the kind of morality we have is
a morality of duty okay rather than a
utilitarian one in which there is as it
were some maximum half
that we could strive for then in that
kind of setting what you have to do is
as it were do what what your duty calls
on you to do but without a sense that
there is some ordering of states of the
world in which one of them is ultimately
best
are you comfortable without Michael well
apart from disagreeing with it yes I
guess I am as I say I perhaps it's
because you live in New York City and I
live in Tallahassee Florida but I I I
don't want to be a bore about this but I
just worry about absolute goods or moral
realism of some sense like that because
I see again and again with people that
I'm dealing with students and not so
much faculty but certainly outside
people who are absolutely convinced that
they know the truth that this is the
truth and if it's not up for debate I
mean for instance you and I might differ
for instance about which what the best
kind of coat is to wear in this sort of
weather now I've got a Barbour coat
you've got you know something else and I
could well see that we you know we might
debate it we might not convince each
other but we wouldn't go away thinking
wow you [ __ ] that guy is because he
just doesn't see the absolute truth that
Barbour coats are better than anything
and there's a it gets a kind of rigidity
about it and that I think is what really
worries me about the absolute truth
thing is you might say well of course it
doesn't mean to say that absolute truth
isn't true but it makes me very
uncomfortable about accepting it and
experience has taught me in my 78 years
that if I'm uncomfortable about
accepting something it's probably
because there's a moral nag behind it
somewhere and I'm trying to paper over
something and that so as I say that's
more or less where I stand
obviously and I think this is a good
thing I'm inquiring
than telling you and I what I for me
it's a dialogue usually with myself but
I'm happy to make it with others to são
Paulo absolute good is dangerous here
yes now let me this is a very very good
little bit of reasoning to have out on
the table because I think it moves many
people and if it moves somebody as
distinguished as Michael ruse it's very
very important to see whether there is
anything to it and the answer is there
is nothing to it to be provocative
listen take a case where there is simply
no doubt that there are objective
absolutely let's just use objective
because absolute somewhat misleading
science ok let's take the physical world
now if what you say is true that if
somebody believes that something is
objectively true that that's a morally
problematic thing because you're going
to ram it down somebody else's throat
who disagrees with you then we may as
well give up objectivity in science as
well the idea that there is a way the
physical world is take the case that's
close to your heart evolution what shall
we say look there are people who think
that evolution is objectively true but
what a dangerous thing to think because
we're going to ram it down the throat of
the creationist well look first of all
the belief that there is a fact of the
matter about some area is completely
independent of what you go on to do with
those beliefs how you treat those
beliefs how you treat people who
disagree with you what level of
tolerance you show what level of respect
what level of you know accommodating the
instincts that they're bringing to the
table are totally different things and
we see this all the time in the case of
science where no one will dispute that
there is a fact of the matter about what
we're talking about so this is a
standard canard ok I mean take and and
to see this very very clearly that
absolutism or objectivism about morality
is not the issue think of what would
happen if we're all relativists ok let's
the state would that be a better would
that be a better normatively better
world for all of us I mean suppose that
the north's had taken the view about the
south well look who are we to say that
slavery is wrong right it's good for
them we don't want that fine we'll just
kind of have a nice little separation
and we let slavery continue nobody
thinks that was a good thing sometimes
having a conviction and acting on it
brings about great moral progress
lifting people out of poverty great
moral progress the vote in Ireland that
suppose great moral progress but there
being a fact of the matter and you're
being convinced of it and how you then
go on to treat other people are two
separate things for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
institutes of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you